So, ich bin nochmal am Start auch wenn es recht spät ist, mussten wir mal wieder sein.
Obbei was heißt mal wieder, gestern haben wir auch schon gestreamt, davor auch, letzten
Tag, was heißt man mal wieder, letzten Tage war doch sogar eigentlich relativ viel.
Wir haben übrigens bald wieder Bastelstream, morgen, wenn wir Glück haben, mit gebastelt
und zwar, ich hab mir ja sowas gekauft, ich hab mir ja, ich hab mir vernetzt, also funk
vernetztbare Rauchmelder gekauft, sollte ich mal kurz das Headset entwirren, ganz kurz.
So, ich glaub so ist besser, was ist das eigentlich für ein Knopf hier, ah ne da hat man nix
mehr, super Knopf, also ich hab mir ja funkvernetzbare Rauchmelder gekauft und ich hab mir so ne,
also das ist, sind funkvernetzbare Rauchmelder und so eine Steuerung vom Hersteller, die eigentlich
gedacht ist an die, also so ne Warnanlage anzuschließen, aber die haben 3 Output Relays
und eins der Output Relays ist eben, schaltet eben, wenn einer der Feuermelder anschlägt
und das ist kaputt, was ich mir gekauft hab, das heißt morgen kommt das nächste und das
probieren wir dann gleich mal zusammen aus, ob ich einfach nur zu blöd war das zu bedienen
oder ob das alte wirklich kaputt war, weil das, bei löten müssen wir da glaube ich
gar nicht so viel, ich hab den Stecker ja schon dran, den kann ich vom alten nehmen,
jetzt gucken wir uns dann morgen mal an, ja moin leute, choice das neueste Fireship Video,
das neueste Fireship Video hab ich noch nicht gesehen, aber ich hab's aufgemacht, das gucken
wir uns gleich zusammen an, Levels passen, hast du Urlaub oder warum so oft da, nein
ich bin wieder etwas halbwegs gesund, nachdem ich mich jetzt 4 oder 5 Wochen oder was das
war, mit Entzündung im Hals rumgeschlagen hab, ein Nachteil hat das mit Entzündung
im Hals, ich hab jetzt so Pillen, die dafür sorgen, dass es besser heilt, aber gleichzeitig
sorgen die dafür, dass mein Immunsystem nicht so fit ist, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt rausgehe
und Corona kriege, dann sterbe ich wahrscheinlich, nein das ist übertrieben wahrscheinlich
sterbe ich nicht, aber ich werde wahrscheinlich, also die Chance richtig krank zu werden ist
auf jeden Fall deutlich höher jetzt, nachdem ich diese Pillen genommen hab, gegen meine
Entzündung im Hals und deswegen bin ich da überhaupt kein Fan von nach Frankfurt zu
fahren, Brezerif, schön, dass du auch da bist, aber heute mal kein Svelte, Lofos1, 10
Monate Dankeschön für die Hypersubscriptions hier, aber ne ich hab kein Urlaub, Urlaub hab
ich erst wieder richtig lang im Dezember und das sind ja noch leider 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10 Monate oder je nachdem wie man es, ne 10 Monate kann nicht sein, ich hab mich
verzählt, ergibt da eigentlich auch keinen Sinn, es sind 9 Monate, eigentlich sind es
nur noch 8 Monate bis Dezember, eigentlich sind es ja nur noch 8 Monate, ich hab ja immer
quasi schon letzte Novemberwoche auch Urlaub, eigentlich muss ich nur noch 8 Monate durch
halten, dann hab ich wieder 1 Monat Urlaub, ja ne die Entzündung im Hals war nicht wegen
Gachibas, du hast gerade mein Video geschaut, nice, du meinst das Homeoffice Video, das
da, das da, übrigens dieses Emoji, wer sich gefragt hat, was hat, was hat dieses Emoji
damit zu tun, nichts, aber dieses Emoji ist neu im letzten Unicode Standard und ist jetzt
auf den meisten Betriebssystemen verfügbar, Microsoft ist da nicht so schnell und ich
dachte mir, hier ist ein Bild vom Strand, warum machen wir nicht einfach so ein Melting Emoji
rein, ich hätte auch Monarch S reinmachen können, das ist gut, das schauen wir uns
gleich an, das Problem ist ehrlich gesagt, mir ist egal ob ich nach Frankfurt fahren muss
oder nicht, das Problem ist mit der Bahn fahren, also jetzt hab ich falsch gesagt, es ist egal
ob ich die Bahn jetzt nach Frankfurt fahren müsste oder in irgendeiner x-beliebliche
andere Stadt, das Problem ist Bahn fahren und das ist absolute Zumutung, es ist einfach
nicht eines Landes angemessen, was das viertgrößte, wo haben wir denn jetzt das Bahn Emoji,
es ist einfach nicht angemessen für ein Land, das die viertgrößte Industrienation der
Welt ist, ich mein vor uns sind nur die China-Chinesen, die USA und Japan, ich glaube es war Japan,
wenn ich nicht ganz durcheinander geraten bin, die mehr Stonks machen als wir und dafür
ist unsere Infrastruktur ziemlich beschissen, Streamer Montags, ja warum nicht, Poggers,
warum, wann ich mal wieder Battlefield 3 auf Ehre, auf Ehre, ja, weiß ich nicht, wann
ich auf Ehre Battlefield 3 spiele wieder, auf meinen Nacken, Alter, ich hab ne Weile
Battlefield 3 nicht mal angeschmissen, aber es bleibt ja aktuell gar nichts anderes übrig,
Battlefield 2042 Sucked, mega, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Sekunde, die Sache die ich in
jedem Stream am Anfang, nein, nein, nicht Cyberpunk, die Sache die ich in jedem Stream
am Anfang machen muss ist eine Runde Cacken über die Spielerzahlen von Battlefield, wollen
wir mal gucken wie viel Battlefield 3 spielen, das sind aber wenige, das sind ziemlich wenige
auf Steam, ja 230, aber passt mal auf, Battlefield 4 spielen teilweise mehr und das nur über
Steam, obwohl es Jahre nicht auf Steam verfügbar war, spielen fast mehr, 24 Hour Peak, also
spielen mehr Leute Battlefield 4 als Battlefield 2042 und das muss man sich immer auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen, also auf Steam, auf Steam, ja und das obwohl es irgendwie erst 5 Jahre
später oder so auf Steam gekommen ist, ja doch mittlerweile gibt es den Krempel auf
Steam, aber das startet glaube ich im Endeffekt einfach nur Origin, das ist also ziemlich
useless, Fortnite hat endlich den Boomer Mode eingeführt, das habe ich gehört, es gibt
jetzt eine Season in Fortnite ohne Bilder, was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, weil ist nicht
Bauen eigentlich so eines der Haupt Gameplay Mechanics von Fortnite, weiß jemand wie das
in der Fortnite Community ankommt, wird das eher gehatet oder eher gefeiert, dass das
Bauen rausfliegt für die Season, ich bin im Fortnite Game bin ich überhaupt nicht drinnen,
es schön wenn dir das gefällt, ja Teilzeit beste, ab wann ist bei dir soweit, ab wann
geht es los, mein Plugin zum Anzeigen funktioniert nicht mehr und seitdem ich das letzte Mal
fast Monka Toske gebaitet wurde, ach das habe ich gesehen, das fand ich nicht gut, ab
1.6., ja du hast es ja fast geschafft, März ist ja quasi vorbei, also musst du im Prinzip
nur noch, wer hat sich bei Microsoft eigentlich gedacht, dass der Pfeil nach oben einen Monat
nach hinten geht, warum geht der Pfeil nach oben nicht einen Monat nach vorne, welche,
ich meine welches Monaks Gehirn bei Microsoft hat sich das ausgedacht, das ist einfach nur
maximal irritierend, Monat nach oben sollte nicht zurück gehen sondern nach vorne und
dann einfach in die umgekehrte Richtung sliden lassen und alles ist gut, also musst du ja
im Prinzip, musst du ja eigentlich nur noch April und Mai überleben, dann hast du Teilzeit,
auf was hast du gewechselt, auch 4 Tage oder noch weniger, Pfeile links und rechts wären
by the way auch ziemlich gut für vor und zurück anscheinend hoch und runter, weil vor und
zurück ist man mit Pfeilen links und rechts kommt man damit eher klar, echt ich nicht,
aber hoch für Monat runter ergibt doch keinen Sinn, was, achso wenn man so einen kompletten
Kalender hat, ja aber da musst du kein Icon zum scrollen drücken, Subway beste, so guck
mal hier, ne das ist nicht das neueste Fireship Video, das ist das neueste Fireship Video
ne, ja das können wir uns gleich angucken, ich hab gesehen, dass es hier empfohlen wird,
gucken wir uns da gleich zusammen an, Subway P-Pro-Fat, ich war legit bestimmt die letzten
4 Jahre oder länger nicht mehr beim Subway, ne Level Capture Bane gibt es heute nix, haben
wir schon geguckt, ich war nicht mehr beim Subway und ich gehe auch nicht mehr zum Subway,
weil, also was ich ja immer übelst gerne gegessen habe ist Subway Steak and Cheese,
haben die das unbenannt, Chili Beef and Cheese, ist das nicht immer Steak and Cheese früher?
Ah ne hier gibt es hier gibt es noch Steak and Cheese, ja das da genau, das da, das hab
ich übelst gerne gegessen früher, aber ich war 2 mal bei einem Subway bei uns in Frankfurt
in der Mittagspause und ich hatte danach so krass die Scheißerei, aber das muss nicht
unbedingt jetzt an Subway allgemein liegen, sondern an dem Subway und seitdem bin ich
nie wieder zum Subway gegangen, wobei es nicht so schlimm war, wie als ich mal bei einem
Lieferservice bestellt hab hier bei mir in Hanau, hab ich bei einem Lieferservice bestellt
und ich hatte wirklich, ich wusste gar nicht was wie mir geschieht, ich wusste nicht wie
mir geschieht, ich hatte zum ersten Mal eine Lebensmittelvergiftung und ich sag euch, ich
war 5 Tage oder 5, 6 Tage fast eine ganze Woche am Stück einfach nur im Arsch, ja im Klo war
ich auch, aber ich war einfach eine komplette Woche im Arsch mit der Lebensmittelvergiftung
und das war so krass, ich hab sogar eine Nachricht vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen, dass ich eine
meldepflichtige Krankheit habe, nachdem ich mal am Arzt war, wusste ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt
gar nicht und es ist nicht Corona, Alter, hör mal auf, na ich hab's ausgefüllt, doch
ich hab's ausgefüllt, ich hab vor allem ausgefüllt, dass ich den Lieferservice mag, da hast du
schon mal ein Video drüber gemacht, echt, ja kann sein, ich hab auch ein Video drüber
gemacht, wo ich im Zug fast mal in Gang gekackt hab, so aber genug jetzt der merkwürdigen
Stories hier, was war es am Ende, nein, nein, nein, es war nicht Salmonellen, es waren,
ich hab's euch mal erzählt, ich hab's vergessen, ähm, Bakter, äh, Bakter, Darm, gibt's denn
da, Kampelobakter, ich glaub, ich glaub das ist es, ich glaub das hatte ich, ich glaube
das war das, ja und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich mir durch das Rahmschnitzel vom Lieferservice
das Ganze zugezogen hab, Durchfallerkrankung, aber wie Leute, ich sag's euch, das hat,
das hat geflutscht, ja das kann im Zweifelsfall tödlich sein, deswegen ist es meldepflichtig,
guck mal, ich meine, es steht nicht umsonst, nur zwei über Ebola, hey nur zwei Punkte
über Ebola, also kurz dran vorbeigeschrammt, ja, ich mein nicht, dass die Reihenfolge
ja alphabetisch wäre oder so, steht da eigentlich Corona auch drinne, wie, warum steht da Corona
nicht drin, da steht SARS bestimmt drin oder sowas, ne auch nicht, ja keine Ahnung, zumindest
das hatte ich und das war wirklich eklig und ich hatte noch nie das Gefühl, ich kannte
das Gefühl gar nicht, dass wenn man im Bett liegt und aufstehen will, man automatisch
wieder zurück ins Bett gezogen wird, das ist ganz, ganz komisch, ich hatte auch 40 Fieber
und so, also das war echt, das war echt nicht spaßig und seitdem hab ich auch nie wieder
bei diesem Lieferdienst was bestellt und werd ich auch nie wieder machen, ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher, dass es da dran gelegen hat, es kommen nur zwei Lieferdienste in Frage, den ich den
Scheiß jetzt, also Scheiß im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, den ich, den ich, den ich in Frage
komme, das ist einmal mein Dönermann um die Ecke, aber da hab ich schon sehr oft bestellt
und nie Probleme gehabt, außerdem passt das zeitlich auch nicht so ganz oder der Lieferservice,
wo ich mir Rahmschnitzel bestellt hab, da hab ich noch nicht so oft bestellt und Rahmschnitzel
ist ja, bietet sich ja gerade an so nen Müll zu übertragen, es war nicht schön, ja, so
viel kann ich sagen, es war echt nicht schön, dieses Emote, ok, was ist das Chainlord, zeig
her, Zulul, es gibt ein neues Zulul Emote, Wahnsinn, haben wir noch das klassische Zulul
oder ist das weg, wir haben kein Zulul mehr, ok Chainlord weil du es bist, es gibt jetzt
ein neues Zulul, add to channel hat nicht funktioniert, warum nicht, Chainlord ich kann
nix ändern, es ist kaputt, Bella Twitch TV, oh, ich hab 100 Emotes voll bei Bella Twitch
TV, Leute wir müssen mal, wir müssen mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen was aussortieren,
ich hab noch das original Zulul drinnen, warum geht denn das nicht, ich hab noch das original
Zulul drinnen, das ist anscheinend broken oder, ist das banned, ok, dann mach ich das
Zulul raus und dein Zulul rein, alles klar, bam, passt, ist drin, banned, warum ist Zulul
banned, ok, muss ich nicht verstehen, hast du dir mal angesehen, files.community, ich
mach so Seiten nicht im Stream auf, achso, das ist irgendein File Explorer oder sowas,
das ist Modern File Explorer, ok, das ist quasi Windows Explorer nur in gut oder wie
darf man sich das vorstellen, warum sind da Symbole von Mega gerade drin gewesen, habt
ihr das auch gesehen, da war grad Google Drive und Mega irgendwie, Mega, Sekunde Leute, Mega,
Upload Song, ich hab zu viele Tabs, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, Treeup.
Ja, also was hab ich hier grade gesehen, ein Windows Explorer Replay, guck mal da, Google
und mega das könnte man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren wo kann man das downloaden microsoft
store monka s ok genug mega upload reicht schon monka s wer benutzt denn den microsoft
store gibt's den für linux ich fürchte mal nein so wir gucken jetzt das fireship video
weil das immer nice was der so treibt wirklich gerne von dem immer schon kurz und knackig
mega ist der nachfolger von mega upload ja das stimmt wohl allerdings hatte das ja schon
vor der ganzen weile an die china chinesen verkaufen was auch immer die da treiben kein
schimmer ich meine nicht dass das ursprünglich super vertrauenserweckend war oder so schauen
wir uns das mal an zulu ist band aufgrund von plek facing ok da wenn das so ist und warum
ist dann das andere zulu erlaubt und und zulu selber nicht was auch immer ich muss das alles
nicht verstehen heutzutage du vermisst den winners explorer dolphin ist gut aber ich
mag den winners explorer ich mag den winners explorer tatsächlich auch und zwar für eine
sache dass sie mittlerweile hier so was wie recent files drinne haben und ich in mein
wegas für video bearbeitung immer direkt von hier check und trocken kann den rest benutze
ich nicht hatten die nicht mal sagte mal hat hat der explorer und der winners elf nicht
mittlerweile sogar tabs
ne soll er jetzt bekommen das soll er schon seit fünf jahren bekommen oder so so also
gucken wir uns mal das fire ship video an 10 very promising open source projects you haven't
heard of nachdem es fire ship ist und ich den gerne gucken und nur 5 minuten 28 mache
ich jetzt nicht das was ich bei solchen videos immer mache einfach in die in die beschreibung
gucken und das video skippen
ich habe zu viele tabs langsam aber sicher habe ich habe ich echt auch für meine meine
begriffe zu viele tabs so schauen wir uns mal an also fire ship erzählen uns was ist welche
open source projekte müssen wir benutzen i just discovered a way to build a billion dollar
startup entirely from free open source software from the most talented programmers in the world
actually everybody knows that already like why pay an engineer when you can just use their stuff
for free on github in today's video we're going to get off the smart kids homework and look at
some of the coolest open source libraries that you've never heard of tools
also geldausgeben bezahlen ist ja wirklich cringe ja das kenne ich das kenne ich das haben wir
sogar schon mal aus spaß an der freude im stream verwendet das ist eigentlich wirklich
eine ganz gute sache aber ich konnte mich nie dazu durchringen the fuck zu verwenden als als
programm wenn du dich verschreibst und dann in der kommando zeile eingibst the fuck oder ich glaube
eigentlich nur fack dann auto korrigiert dass dein letztes kommando wurde dich verschrieben
hast normally when you type a command into the terminal and make a typo in your head and then
retype the command from scratch the fuck makes this process much more intuitive allowing you to
simply type fuck into the terminal then it will attempt to reformat your command automatically to
be honest ich war ganz ganz ernst wenn das wenn es dich sogar fragt du hast dreimal schneller
noch mal neu getippt anstatt fack zu tippen und dann zu sagen not enter also das ist eher so
so fürs miemen das program ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich so sinnvoll ist hast du schon
mal an open source projekte gespendet ja habe ich doch gar nicht so lange her ich habe hardware
gespendet was heißt gespendet ja doch kann man so nennen ich habe hardware gespendet und zwar
moment ich muss mein hemd mal ein bisschen weg meines kratzer mikrofon github a t c
thermometer ich habe ihm hier drei hardware drei thermometer gesponsert dass er die firmware die
neueste die neueste firmware beziehungsweise die neueste hardware revision reverse engineering
kann dass das display funktioniert bei revision 2 für das show me thermometer natürlich muss ich
jetzt auch mal ehrlich halber ehrlich halber sagt natürlich nicht ganz unnützlich weil ich
habe den kram und es hat nicht funktioniert ich habe zehn stück bestellt bei aliexpress und
drei stück habe ich gespendet also insofern ja ich habe schon mal gespendet für open source
projekte das ist nicht das einzige mal ich habe für custom firmware für meine kamera schon was
gespendet ansonsten fällt mir grad nichts ein hast du erfahrung sekunde was hast du erfahrung
mit open vpn möchte ein vps ins heimnetz integrieren ja ich würde nicht open vpn nehmen ich würde
wireshark nicht wireshark wire guard nehmen mittlerweile macht mein boomer gehirn da nicht
mal mit außerdem ist schon spät ja die programme die alle so ähnlich heißen so jetzt gucken wir
das video ab jetzt mal am stück ohne dass ich permanent hier unterbreche problem that anybody
who's ever built a website is faced it's too slow even if you work really hard to create a tiny
javascript bundle the product manager will eventually tell you to add a bunch of other
job like mixpanel intercom and google analytics these third party scripts clog up the main
thing will make your app slow no matter what luckily there's an open source library called party town
that can run this case for me web zufälligerweise habe ich letztes video aber modern browsers allow
you to run background jobs via web workers party town leider leider leider ist multithreading im
browser wirklich pains champ hoch zehn leider so that don't deal directly with the ui into a web
worker and that means the only thing on the main thread is your ui which was a problem that every
app developer will need to solve is user authentication firebase is great but it's somewhat feature
limited so lange man kein login für seine seite braucht es alles in ordnung off the zero is great
but it's expensive and that brings us to super tokens which is an open source authentication solution
it provides sdks for runtimes like node and python allowing you to quickly self-host a fully
featured authentication system with support providers passwordless login but most importantly it
deals with management and security pretty cool but it's got nothing on this next one hi mom is a
blazingly fast javascript library in record time here's a pro tip wait a minute ist ist das jetzt
ein witz oder gibt es das wirklich warum gibt es denn für alles eine javascript library alles blazing
fast javascript library to say hi das ist ein witz das ist 100 proinz das ist so so meme library
um zu zeigen ja javascript libraries keck weh if you're building an open source library make
sure that the readme includes phrases like blazingly fast and bleeding edge holistic
approach because they make your library better the same way putting the same way putting flame
stickers on a car makes it go faster next up we have a two-for-one many businesses out there need
to build their own full-tech search engine either for internal data or to build a search engine for
their customers you could go with elastic surge but it's expensive and complicated there are two
very promising open source a trick verraten du kannst das meiste was du an datenbanken
brauchst was du an also an relationalen datenbanken brauchst was du an time series datenbanken
brauchst was du an dokument basierten datenbanken brauchst was du an full text search und was du an
autocomplete und text indexing brauchst was du kannst fast alles mit postgres erschlagen fast
alles die haben postgres kann alles du brauchst eigentlich gar nichts anderes mehr das problem
ist nur dass man sich erstmal ein bisschen durchkämpfen muss aber eigentlich kann postgres
quasi im prinzip könntest du fast 90 prozent dieser dinge einstellen und durch postgres ersetzen
alternatives one is melee search implemented in rust and the other is ink implemented ok ok
allein schon dadurch dass es in rust implementiert ist wenn die leute das benutzen und ich muss sagen
ich bin ja bei manchen sachen wie soll ich sagen also ich muss normalerweise bin ich ja sehr
wie nennt man das pragmatisch bei dem was ich verwende ja also wenn ich ein produkt sehe was
passt dann denke ich mir ok warum nicht ja kann man verwenden auch wenn ich vielleicht anderes
von denen nicht mag ist ja egal aber in dem fall manchmal bin ich da so ein bisschen impulsiv auch
bei der entscheidung und zwar wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste jetzt hier ich habe beides
noch nie benutzt wenn ich mich zwischen my research oder oder senk entscheiden müsste würde ich
my research nehmen weil die webseite besser aussehen in hübschen slogan sagt nichts über
die qualität der software aus ja wahrscheinlich würde ich mir deswegen das zuerst marken und
rast und es ist in rust programmiert in rust programmiert sein hat in dem fall für mich
tatsächlich ein vorteil wenn ich das nämlich embedden will wenn ich das embedden will ist
das mit rust also mal angenommen ich mache mal mache irgendwie meine c sharp web anwendung
sp dort net core da ist interop mit rust umlängen um welten einfacher als mit go interop mit go ist
müll go funktioniert gut mit go und sonst nix interop mit go ist abfuck also c interfaces für
go ist komplett für den arsch und dann hast du das problem dass go calls also calls in go rein
übelsten overhead haben und calls quasi von go nach c ne umgedreht calls von go nach c
auf übelsten overhead haben und co und calls von unmanaged in go rein noch mehr overhead haben das
macht bei den meisten sachen zwar kein großartigen unterschied aber es nervt mich und ja ich weiß
das ist im prinzip egal wenn du irgendwelche web requests schickst aber wenn du die möglichkeit
hast das irgendwie zu embedden ist natürlich noch cooler da musst du keinen extra web service noch
zuletzt nicht laufen lassen oder sowas also c interfaces in rust ist wirklich einfach
ja rust ist rust ist nur für für high iq leute allein schon die rust syntax die rust syntax ist
im vergleich zu c++ logisch aber kompliziert und c++ ist kompliziert weil unlogisch und
übertrieben bloatet ist es nicht einfach mittlerweile so dass go statt python genommen
wird und russia z nö es hat alles seine daseinsberechtigung vielleicht mal außer c++ aber
nein sogar c++ gerade wenn wenn man in der game entwicklung guckt da ist ja alles irgendwie
in c++ unrealist in c++ unity ist ja auch intern in c++ glaube ich oder 10 ich glaube c++ zum
glück kompilieren die c sharp nach c++ und dann kann man das halbwegs ertragen und go
und python kannst du schlecht das eine durch das andere ablösen weil es einfach komplett
unterschiedliche ansätze hat was ist denn bitteschön nicht plotet ich trpc ist exceptionally cool
but a little harder to explain if you're building an api today there are two main approaches rest
in graph ql i won't go into the differences right now although i do have videos but there's
another less talked about approach called rpc or remote procedure call and basically it's
just a url on a server but like bites strike recht die chat brain idees die sind auch bloatet
aber gut plotet rest that corresponds to an entity it corresponds to a function this approach
actually makes a ton of sense for many modern applications trpc allows you to build entirely
type ja ganz ehrlich grpc wollte ich tatsächlich auch schon mich längere zeit mal intensiver
mit beschäftigen ich habe immer mal am rande so ein bisschen was gemacht aber nie großartig
was ich glaube das ist was das brauchst du wahrscheinlich nicht heute also das brauchst
du nicht jeden tag aber wenn du es brauchst und ein bisschen ahnung davon hast dass du genau
einschätzen kannst wann du es benutzen sollst glaube ich die richtig gute geschichte hat jemand
von euch mit grpc was gemacht also also ich stelle es mir ich stelle es mir wirklich cool vor für
bestimmte sachen mir fällt jetzt kein beispiel ein zum beispiel wenn du irgendwelche sachen
streamen willst oder so also irgendwelche daten streamen willst die auf dem server generiert
werden und auf den client gestreamt werden sollen oder irgendwie soll so geschichten also da stelle
ich mir schon ziemlich cool vor aber ich habe damit kaum was gemacht bisher aber ich glaube es ist
wirklich nice und wenn man sich damit beschäftigt hat dann weiß man nämlich auch wann man es gut
gebrauchen kann
hallo unser haus hat einen kabelanschluss aber in der wohnung im erdgeschoss gibt es nur eine
tae dose was für einen aufwand ist das eine kabeldose zu machen ja wo hast du denn eine
kabelanschluss dann im keller oder was
ja
du müsstest du müsstest irgendwie wenn du das wenn du das haben willst du müsstest halt irgendwie
einen koachs kabel ins erdgeschoss bekommen
wo hast du denn den kabelanschluss
komplett raus aus dem thema lul ja wo hast du denn den kabelanschluss der kompati im keller raus
oder wie und ja gut da muss sie irgendwie kabel hochlegen wenn es im erdgeschoss haben
willst anders da geht das nicht ja da geht es doch gerade darum er hat im keller einen
kabelanschluss aber im ersten stock hat er plus eine telefondose und deswegen hat er
keinen kabelanschluss
achso ja gut wenn die nicht mal dir ist das muss dann jeder vermieter machen du kannst
ja nicht einfach die wand bohren aber wenn das nicht dir ist
muss du dem sagen sach hier gib her gift please
je nachdem was du machen willst wenn du fernseh gucken willst bringt das nicht allzu viel
sei denn du machst sowas wie dvbc tuner unten und dann über ip drüber und so also
je nachdem was man machen will aber wie gesagt ich glaube der keller und die
wohnung gehört dir ja eh nicht also kannst du da eh nichts selbst bohren
kann ich dir nicht sagen es kommt darauf an wie sehr du dich auskennst ich weiß nicht was man
als informatik informatikor techniker so lernen muss aber ganz ehrlich was man fisi technisch
lernt ist auch nicht super kompliziert und kriegen die meisten auch easy hin also wirst
du das wahrscheinlich auch schaffen wie sinnvoll findest du es dass ein fach informatik anwendungs
entwicklung im fünften ausbildungsmodell eine cloud und data center admin zertifizierung
führt für ernsthaft dafür gibt es zertifizierung wirklich
geier zertifizierung ich müsste ehrlich gesagt nicht was daran
irgendwie was man damit anfangen soll aber hey wenn es deinen arbeitgeber toll findet
und im endeffekt unserem strich dadurch vielleicht auch mal mehr springen lässt warum nicht ja wenn
du den kram bezahlt kriegst machs warum nicht bock hätte ich auch nicht drauf sei ich dir ganz
ehrlich so wir muss jetzt endlich mal das video fertig gucken
without the need for schemas or cogeneration like you would with graph ql overall i think it
has the potential to fundamentally simplify the way we build full stack web applications speaking
of simplification one company that has simplified the modern database is air table the only problem
habe ich noch nie benutzt jemand von euch schon an air table benutzt one is that you have to pay a
company to use it if only there was an open source alternative noco db does exactly that it's an
open source air table that can be built on top of your own my sql or postgres moment das ist ein
aufsatz auf meine postgres und verwende ich nicht meine postgres einfach so war so wozu brauche ich
das ist ja nicht mein postgres kann ja quasi alles zum größten teil was so ziemlich alles andere
auch also dein postgres ist quasi in ein produkt fünf produkte in einem von dem was sie können also
in other words it's an open source noco database or smart spreadsheet as a development das ist
was wo sich die noobs irgendwelche excel tabellen zusammen klicken können ach so das ist das die
personalabteilung sich irgendwelche spreadsheets zusammen basteln kann oder wie oder ach so ist auch
gott ne da da hätte ich keinen bock drauf geben wir gehen wir weg so die game dankeschön elf
monate entwicklung spreadsheet as a developer another piece of software you may want to replace
is postman your http client an awesome open source alternative is hopscotch which is built
nein nein nein nein nein wir verwenden schon lange kein postman mehr wir gehen mit der zeit wir
verwenden post woman das jetzt kein witz das gibt es wirklich they want to replace is postman
your http client an awesome open source alternative is hopscotch which is built with ujs and typescript
entirely dann ist natürlich besser dann ist es natürlich besser wenn sie in vue gs und
typescript entwickelt ist aber muss das muss das besser sein source but you can go use it in the
browser right now at hopscotch i o and now it runs in a native window and allows you to interact
with your file system now if you've ever coded in python then try javascript later you might be
shocked at how difficult was weiß hast du mir das nicht geglaubt dass es das gibt das war kein
schibet das gibt's wirklich ach das ist hopscotch lull ach post woman er heißt jetzt hopscotch das
ziffer ist to work with multi-dimensional arrays ist in python we have libraries like pandas that
can do all kinds of useful stuff to an array or data frame not many people realize that there's a
library called danfo js danfo js habe ich auch nie gehört powerful javascript data analysis tool
das mit das ist mir zu advanced alleinst die überschrift das ist inspired by pandas and can
do many of the things you know and love like read a csv file and process the data within it before
it gets sent to a machine learning library like tensorflow that's pretty useful but the hardest
thing in front and web development seriously seriously ich glaube ich musste noch nie in javascript eine csv
datei verarbeiten aber das mag anders sein wenn man not im backend verwendet dann muss man so
ekliche dinger manchmal machen aber ich bin glücklicherweise um csv datei in den letzten
jahren zum größten teil rumgekommen wir haben wir haben auf der arbeit eine csv datei aber
ansonsten also eine riesen csv datei aber ansonsten ein open source leco
in your website look good there's a million different tools out there that can help you do that but one i've
been really loving recently for react is manting not only does not only does like this nice looking
timeline but it also has a bunch of built-in hooks that handle many of the annoying things that you'll
come across when building a webapp was können csv datei schlecht lesbar im editor sein können die
das kann ich ziemlich gut und und sich mit fehlern in tabellenkalkulation importieren lassen weil man
nicht den richtigen separator verwendet hat und in a collection of items on top of that it has
optional packages for a notification system rich text editor and a drop zone for file uploads it's
so awesome that we use it in one of the demo apps in the full react course on fireship io check it
out if you want to build a serious app with react now the problem is that they require you to know
how to write some code if you have an idea for a full stack application but want to skip the whole
learn to code part an open source tool to check out is amplification it's a tool that can
automatically generate both your front-end and back-end code based on relationships to data
model ich generate in mein front-end und mein back-end aus irgendeinem datenbank schema jetzt
wird es aber fai fertig ob da was gescheites rauskommt was in a database that you can manage
visually the back-end is built with other open source tools like node nest js and prisma while
the front-end is based on react even if you do know how to code this is open source libraries
to try out in your next project hit the like button and subscribe thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one nur durch das chat nur dass jetzt euch richtig verstehe oder wolle
dass ich richtig verstehe ihr habt auf der arbeit 1,5 peter beidt csv dateien wirklich
das ist das weiß ich nicht ob ich das aushalten würde ist ja nicht ursprünglich mein angular
entwickler gewesen möglich möglich ja aber irgendwann muss früher oder später ja mal jeder
merken dass angular miss misst ist ich verstehe vieles an excel nicht ja ich auch nicht ernsthaft
ja gut es war wahrscheinlich zu zeiten wo angular noch nicht ein riesengroße bloated mess war
angular kann man immer gut flamen excel datenbanken beste so ich dachte excess datenbanken sind die
besten gibt es gibt es excess eigentlich noch
scheiße das gibt es ja immer noch sache gibt sachen die sterben einfach nicht excess
boah wenn ich das schon sehe die wollen wir noch nicht ernsthaft erzählen das sieht aus
wie ein programm aus 2022 man das sieht aus wie ein programm von 1998 immer noch excess
ich halte es nicht mehr aus ja in der schule sollten wir auch mal was mit excess machen das
war bei dem lehrer recycle story incoming das kennt ihr ja schon das war bei dem lehrer
der eigentlich keine ahnung von computer krams und IT und sonst was hatte wo wir quasi zweieinhalb
jahre oder drei jahre in diesem fach was ich glaube IT system oder irgendwie nannte haben
wir office gemacht und das einzige worauf du bei dem lehrer achten musst ist richtig bei
strikes du weißt das noch dass du deine office dokument in lila gemacht hast und dann hat er
sich hingestellt hat gesagt leila leila leila noch eins gekriegt das war weird champ ganz grausam
ganz ganz schlimm also das habe ich nie verdaut IT in der IT unterricht in der schule von jemanden
absolut kein von über 1000 blasen absolut keine ahnung was geht mit der mario kart musik ab
dieser sehr hartnäckig gerade ja besser so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an
playstation 3 emulation auf dem pc ist impressive das wird mich wundern wenn das
gescheit funktioniert wahrscheinlich ist ps3 emulation impressive weil überhaupt mal jetzt
ein spiel startet ist das ne das ist das ist nicht bleibt das ist nicht was ist und das
funktioniert wirklich ja also ps ohne scheiß ps3 emulator ist also
generell ps3 hardware ist absolutes hexenwerk hat man ja gesehen dass die entwickler auf der
original hardware jahre gebraucht haben sie das überhaupt ordentlich verwenden konnten aber ich
muss sagen die ps3 war die letzte konsolen hardware die wirklich wie soll ich sagen so die
wirklich überrascht und begeistert hat jetzt ist das mehr oder weniger so nur nach 15 pc zeug
aber es hat sich halt nicht wirklich gelohnt und das zu emulieren vergiss es also ich habe ja noch
vor jahren gesagt ich glaube nicht dass wir überhaupt jemals in naher zukunft ps3 emulator
sehen werden aber lag ich anscheinend jetzt ich muss da mal kurz hin ich muss da mal kurz
hin wir machen das mit der vm ich weiß nicht ob die seite monka tos ist wer weiß was man
so untergeschoben kriegt wahrscheinlich nichts ich war mal kurz die vm an ich will mal kurz gucken
wie viel spiele kompatibel sind wie heißt wie ist dieses ding r p c s 3 plus plus entwickelt
das ist ja schon mal wieder grausam zur kompatibility playable sehr gut playable
jetzt wäre die frage kann man das durchspielen gucken wir mal gucken wir mal wie sieht es
denn aus mit fall of duty modern warfare ist playable blu-ray digital
anscheinend funktioniert das ohne probleme außer dass es ab und zu
krascht das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass allen ernstes darauf was was wirklich durchspielbar
lauffähig ist wie ist denn die performance so das werden wir gleich sehen denke ich
die müssen wahrscheinlich erst noch mal die metal dokumentation lesen dass sie den kram
zum laufen bekommen also im prinzip im prinzip der gleiche spaß wieder bei der ps1 was die
emulatoren heute noch nicht mit liefern dürfen
das ist natürlich das natürlich habe ich aber ganz ehrlich ich wundere dass es
überhaupt funktioniert also es ist absoluter wahnsinn die playstation 3 zu emulieren weil
die playstation hardware ab nichts aber auch gar nichts mit so einem standard pc zu tun hat
allein schon dass das läuft ist wirklich eine riesen leistung das muss man wirklich mal
anerkennen also playstation 3 emulator das hat er schon ganz richtig gesagt das dürfte
wahrscheinlich eines der krassesten dinger sein die man überhaupt entwickeln kann
kann man da auch den playstation store verwenden das wird nicht funktionieren
oder das wäre verrückt also nee geht nicht ne nee hätte mich auch sehr gewundert wenn
das funktionieren würde
ich weiß gar nicht was das sein konnte man nicht linux auf der ps3 installieren doch
wahrscheinlich kannst du da linux laufen lassen im emulator was natürlich maximal sinnlos
ist aber es müsste müsste funktionieren ich meine du könntest damit theoretisch unter
linux eine ps3 emulieren auf der du dann das ps3 linux startest unsinnig aber es müsste
funktionieren ich meine da drinne da drinne kannst du dann auch wirklich die die webseite
öffnen du wirst auf dem browser wahrscheinlich mit was war das yellow dog linux oder sowas
auf der ps3 wirst wahrscheinlich keine keine ordentliche webseite anzeigen lassen können
aber wahrscheinlich kannst du flash games darin dann spielen aber da kannst du echt
die scamming der webseite anzeigen musst du keine gedanken machen dass da irgendjemand
ausbricht
ok weiter schuppen
es läuft doch ganz ok ah ne ne ne ne das ruckelt das ruckelt schon das ruckelt ziemlich
guckt euch das mal an das ruckelt ziemlich das sind keine ahnung 12 13 fps oder sowas
20 echt es ruckelt auf jeden fall
das ruckelt
mit einem weiteren 33,5% als in-game zu kommen.
Ein weiterer größter Schaden ist, dass im Oktober 2021
das RPCS3-Team erlaubt hat, dass jedes PS3-Game jetzt in die Emulation ausgebildet wird.
In anderen Worten, es gibt 0%...
Das ist cool. Also ganz ehrlich, sowas zu programmieren ist wirklich massives, Fivehead.
Wollen wir mal auf Git...? Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Nur mal ganz kurz. GitHub, wie heißt dieses Ding? R...?
Wir gucken uns da nicht viel an. Wir gucken uns da nicht viel an.
Ich will das nur mal aufmachen. Und mal zeigen, wie viel das ist.
Die haben doch hier immer Analyse.
Ach, haben die... Konnte man sich nicht line-off...?
Ich dachte, man konnte Code-Zeilen irgendwie zählen.
Hatten die nicht so ein Statistik-Ding?
Insights, genau.
Oh, wo ist denn das nochmal versteckt?
Nö.
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Das ist C++. Ah, yes. Ach ja. Obvious. Obvious. Obvious. Alles klar.
Hier wird...
Wahrscheinlich das Game-Binary irgendwie... Weil die müssen ja quasi die...
Die Codes, also die Instruktionen in dem Game-Binary, müssen die ja quasi on the fly umschreiben in x86 Instruktionen.
Was halt massive 5-Hat-Shit ist, Alter. Guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Ey, war's auch immer...
Aber gut. Ist dann der Emulator auch auf 30 FPS gelockt? Die PS3 war nie auf 30 FPS gelockt?
Nein, in der PS3 ist kein x86...
In der ps3 ist eine mischung aus power power pc ibm power pc und ich glaube 6
So so rechenkerne noch
Das hat mit x86 also es könnte kaum weiter entfernt von normaler x86 architektur sein
für yourself
Ich meine das läuft doch erstaunlich
So dass das ist war einfach ps3 spieler auf dem pc sind
Genau power pc plus plus custom bullshit was wird die playstation 4 ist ziemlich normaler pc ja das stimmt
Was lustig ist ich habe das schon öfters erzählt an der stelle aber ich fand die story damals echt spannend die haben also bei ibm
Dann wurde die cpu entwickelt sowohl für die xbox 360 als auch für die ps3
Und mehr oder weniger von den gleichen leuten die offiziell nichts voneinander wissen durften
Das ist eine richtige gibt gibt sogar ein buch drüber das finde ich fand ich echt spannende geschichte
Und frag mich wie die das gemacht haben
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir noch game play
Ich finde das cool dass es einfach geht
Mittlerweile und man muss ja wirklich sagen dass es einfach geht jedes spiel booted installation ist relativ easy also
Als da muss ich wirklich das ist wirklich echt ein achievement
Das ist wirklich gut ab also in ps3 emulator ist echt absolut krasse geschichte
Sollten wir spielen
Ob der multiplayer funktioniert
Das ist die frage ob du dich online überhaupt, connecten kannst ins psn
Wenn ich ins psn connecten kannst könnte ich mir vorstellen dass multiplayer funktioniert aber keine ahnung
I don't recommend ubuntu any money ist es der dude der uns letztes erzählt hat warum er kann firefox
Das ist nick und ubuntu hat mich in linux in 2000
Das ist der keller letztens erzählt hat
Er verwendet kein firefox mehr dafür den gnome browser und dann im video danach zu sagen ach nee war doch keine so gute idee
Es ist ja nicht so als hätten wir das nicht gleich gewusst
Er hat wirklich critical informations geleckt
lord
Blizzard-massive gamble ist nalling
Weihou这, OK Levelcap
Wir lassen uns, wir lassen noch einmal G-Bane. Komm, der tägliche Level Cap G-Bane.
Ganz ehrlich, Overwatch 2 hyped mich so überhaupt nicht.
Ich meine, wahrscheinlich, wenn ich noch ein paar von den alten Leuten da wieder ein bisschen aktivieren kann, mit denen ich viel Overwatch gespielt habe, vielleicht gucken wir uns das mal an zusammen.
Aber wohl eher nicht im Stream. Ich meine, ich habe hunderte Stunden, wenn nicht tausende Stunden Overwatch gespielt. Und ich meine, ich war alleine in der Beta Level 300 oder sowas.
Oder Level 500 in der Beta, weil wir übertrieben wurden in der Beta schon. Und es ist einfach Bane's Champ, was Blizzard mit dem Game gemacht hat.
Wie viele neue Maps?
Alter!
Vier neue Maps, also ohne Scheiß, Overwatch 2, die können ja wieder anfangen mit, wir machen drei neue Maps in drei Jahren und sowas. Eigentlich müsste das gleich mal 20 neue Maps geben oder so, aber naja, naja, hab da meine Zweifel.
Aha.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass Lucio ursprünglich, jetzt wo ich das hier gerade sehe, wusstet ihr, dass Lucio ursprünglich ein Eishockeyspieler sein sollte aus Kanada?
In der Entwicklungsphase. Und jetzt ist es halt so krasser DJ aus Südamerika.
Was? Hey Max, gestern mal wieder dein Schneestelzen-Video gesehen. Immer noch wieder toll, wenn das vorgeschlagen wird. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was mit dem YouTube-Algorithmus los ist, keine Ahnung.
Excited mich überhaupt nicht. Ja, das hat ja nicht direkt was mit Overwatch zu tun, das ist ja komplett Blizzard-Shit.
Was? Nein, da wäre ja nie einer dran gedacht, dass Bobby mit am... Nein, das hätte man nicht mit rechnen können. Nein, nein, nein.
Ganz ehrlich, Bobby ist das doch alles scheißegal. Wenn es dazu führt, dass der Rubel rollt, geht es dem am Arsch vorbei. Den interessiert das erst, wenn es Geld kostet.
Ansonsten ist das... Es war doch gar keine Frage, ob er das wusste oder nicht. Natürlich wusste er das alles.
Ja. Obwohl er vorher noch ein paar Wochen gesagt... Vor ein paar Tagen davor gesagt hat, so nach dem Motto, den wollen wir nichts zu tun haben.
Neun, Lukas. Der Overwatch League ist ja auch failes. Fuck. Nein, Overwatch League nicht.
Das wundert mich nicht. Aber ganz davon abgesehen, seit der Krempel auf YouTube ist, guckt das doch keine Sau mehr. Sekunde. YouTube Overwatch League.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an, das darf man sich bestimmt nicht angucken hier, weil so und Zeug. Guckt mal hier. Die Top 10 Plays haben 40.000 Views.
Und die letzten Matches waren auch immer die wahren. Guckt mal. Das hat 116.000 Views. Das ist so... Guckt mal. Die Grand Finals hatten 800.000.
Die Grand Finals hatten insgesamt 820.000 Leute. Also die haben nicht insgesamt geguckt, die haben halt mal reingeklickt.
Mittlerweile ist die Overwatch League auf einem Niveau, wo irgendein CSGO Regional Ding mehr Zuschauer hat.
Die Overwatch, es E-Sport-Szene und sogar Blizzard selbst. Die Bequesition von Xbox ist sicherlich, um alles zu schweigen. Hoffentlich ist es alles für das Beste.
Aber wenn die Overwatch League keine neuen Sponsoren erzielen kann, wer sagt, wie lange Blizzard weiter Bankrollen wird?
Wenn ihr mich fragt, ist Overwatch League schon eigentlich gefailt? Schon die letzten drei Jahre?
Ja, und 90.000 Cheater haben sich einen neuen Account gemacht und haben sich dann gedacht, Activision...
Ich meine, allein schon, dass man so einen Stuss machen muss, anstatt die einfach zu bannen.
Ich meine immerhin, immerhin, Warzone ist am Leben, das sieht man daran, es gibt noch Cheater und es gibt noch neue Cheats für das Spiel.
In Battlefield 2042 wurde die Weiterentwicklung von Cheats irgendwie einen Monat nach Release eingestellt. Das ist kein Witz.
Eine große, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, eine große Seite, die Cheats verkauft, hat gesagt, wer einen Battlefield 2042 Cheat gekauft hat, es ist ja ein Abo, es ist ein Abo-Modell, dass die Cheats aktuell bleiben,
der bekommt keine Updates mehr und sein Abo kann, glaube ich, wahlweise umgestellt werden auf Warzone oder Apex oder sowas.
Wenn auch nicht mal die Cheathersteller ihre Cheats für den Game updaten wollen, da weißt du Bescheid.
Ja, das war ja schon gerüchtemäßig am Start, dass ein neues Witcher Game in Entwicklung ist, aber da werden wir bestimmt noch 3 Jahre drauf warten lassen.
Ich kann euch sagen, warum die ihre Inhouse Engine nicht mehr verwenden wollen. Wahrscheinlich haben sie den Cyberpunk verwendet und haben festgestellt, die sind da mittlerweile so am Limit und kriegen ihr Geschiss da drin nicht mehr gebacken.
Sie nehmen irgendwas, wo sie auch Leute finden, die da mit Ahnung haben.
Das Spiel sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Das ist schlecht. Das ist schlecht.
Die einfachste Version ist es, das Spiel so schnell wie möglich abzuwenden, die Map zu öffnen und den Konfirm-Button zu spammen.
Das Spiel ist so schnell wie möglich abzuwenden und den Konfirm-Button zu spammen.
Teams, ja.
Double Shift.
Cringe.
Hackers Backpack.
Top, das haben wir schon. Ah, guck mal da.
Der Hackers Backpack.
I fix it, Kid. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das kann man da tatsächlich rein machen. Why not?
Ich mein, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die allergeilste Werkzeugqualität, aber das ist ein gutes Set.
Gerade die ganzen Rare Bits, die man selten braucht.
Ich musste letztens mal eine Mikrowelle aufschrauben.
Weil sie kaputt war. Der Knopf ging nicht mehr auf.
Da stand noch eine Tasse mit Milch drin in der Mikrowelle.
Das heißt, ich konnte die nicht mal richtig hochheben und wegschmeißen.
Da musste ich letztens die Mikrowelle aufschrauben und gucken, wie man die irgendwie aufkriegt.
Da hat mir das I fix it Toolkit tatsächlich einiges gebracht.
Weil die Mikrowelle mit so super weird champigen Schrauben zu war.
Zahlst du deine Zahnarzttermine auch selber? Nein, das ist mir zu teuer.
Noch gar nichts. Der steht in der Ecke und surfert vor sich hin.
Eine Mikrowelle aufmachen natürlich nicht, wie sie an war.
Ich hab die vom Strom abgemacht, bisschen stehen lassen und dann abgeschraubt.
Ich mach die doch nicht auf, während die an ist.
Ich schmeiß die aber auch bestimmt nicht weg, wenn auch eine Tasse drin steht.
Schauen wir sie jetzt noch mal angucken.
Ken Wireshark spot hidden cameras for free.
Wie soll denn Wireshark Kameras finden?
Ich meine, du kannst, lass mal überlegen, was sie uns da wieder zeigen können.
Ich meine, du kannst natürlich Wi-Fi Zeug mitschneiden.
Und vielleicht irgendwie anhand der Signalstärke oder sowas.
Irgendwie erkennen, wo was sendet oder so vielleicht.
Na ja, mal gucken.
Kommen wir uns mal anschauen.
Denn du musst ja nicht im WLAN drin sein, um WLAN Packages zu empfangen.
Das ist ja das Schöne an WLAN. WLAN geht über die Luft.
Unabhängig, also du kannst WLAN Pakete und du kannst WLAN Traffic prinzipiell ja erkennen,
ohne dass du in diesem WLAN drin bist. Du kannst es halt nicht lesen.
Also jeder, der auf der Straße ist, kann dein WLAN Traffic sehen.
Aber er kann nicht reingucken.
Also beziehungsweise in die Daten nicht reingucken.
Ok, mal gucken. Mal gucken, ob wir gebanet werden in dem Video.
Mal gucken, ob wir gebanet werden.
Warum ist denn die Qualität so kacke?
1080p? Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das ist doch im Leben kein 1080p. Vielleicht muss ich hier mal umschalten.
720p sieht besser aus als 1080p. Sehr gut.
Ah, jetzt sieht 1080p auch besser aus.
Ok.
Das ist doch gestellt.
Was zum?
Ok.
Ja, das ist so eine typische Company Antwort.
Wenn du sagst, Jungs, ihr habt da kacke gebaut, das und das funktioniert nicht,
dann kommt da immer, wir nehmen das aber sehr und sehr ernst und haben jetzt auch unsere Mitarbeiter
nochmal neu geschult. Das hat höchste Priorität bei uns.
Ich meine, es müsste, und es gibt es, das gibt es bestimmt.
Man müsste mal danach suchen, ein Business Response Generator.
Die ganzen öffentlichen Meldungen, die immer rauskommen von irgendwelchen Unternehmen
oder auch die öffentlichen Statements, die lesen sich alle immer gleich.
Ok, wo geht es denn los? Ok, Kamera am Start.
Alter, das Video ist mega langsam.
Nicht langsam.
Was hat das denn jetzt mit Wireshark zu tun?
Aha.
Ok, weiter.
Ein K-18, bestimmt bei AliExpress oder sowas. Ein K-18 Multifunction Anti-Spy Detector.
Reicht dazu nicht einfach ein Notebook mit WLAN?
Ok, mal gucken.
Ok, das sieht mal höchst sus aus, wenn einer so rumläuft.
Ok, weiter.
Was, was, was bin ich hier sehend überhaupt?
Du brauchst einen Empfänger für die bestimmten Frequenzen, das ist ja das Gute an WLAN.
Jedes Notebook mit WLAN hat einen Adapter, der auf den richtigen Frequenzen ist.
Weil WLAN eben nur mal auf festen Frequenzen ist oder auf festen Bändern ist.
So.
Ok, was hat das jetzt mit Wireshark zu tun? Sekunde.
Ich muss mir das mal vorspulen, das mit Two-Pants-Champ, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Ja natürlich, das dachte ich mir. Du kannst ja in Wireshark die Stärke der Pakete erkennen.
Also das kriegt man wahrscheinlich auf die Reihe.
Ja, so hätte ich mir das auch gedacht. Du guckst einfach, welche Signalstärke die Pakete haben.
Und wenn die hoch ist, bist du nah dran. Wenn du weiter weg bist, ist sie niedriger.
So in der Richtung hätte ich mir das jetzt auch gedacht.
Ja gut.
Es gibt sogar Software für das Handy, es gibt sogar Apps für Android, um sowas zu machen.
Unter iOS geht es ein bisschen schwieriger, da haben die Apps nicht so viel Zugriff drauf.
Das ist jetzt nicht warum man da so ein komisches Detektor, die Wires braucht.
Er läuft mit dem Notebook um und guckt, wo WLAN-Pakete ankommen, die hohe Signalstärke haben.
Richtig krasser Hacker-Shit.
Okay, alles klar. Jetzt weiß ich auch nicht. Wirklich Weird-Champ-Video.
Keine Ahnung, was mir das sagen sollte jetzt.
Okay, sechs Minuten, bin ich mal gespannt, was die erzählen.
Ich bin nur wirklich kein Fan vom Windows-Desktop oder sonst was.
Aber das ist bei weitem nicht so ein Durcheinander wie unter Linux. Allein schon der Paket-Manager.
So viele Tabs offen. Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich habe hier noch mehr Tabs offen.
Das reicht nicht. Ich habe zwei Browser-Fenster mit fast vollen Tabs.
Und so ist das richtig. Du darfst die Schrift nicht mehr lesen können auf dem Tabs.
Solange du die Schrift noch lesen kannst auf den Tabs, dann ist es nicht genug Tabs.
Allein schon Sachen über einen ordentlichen Paket-Manager installieren ist mal weilenweit besser als unter Windows.
Aber gucken wir uns mal an, was sie uns erzählen. Ich meine, wir können auch einfach.
Nee, können wir nicht.
Ja, ich benutze Linux täglich. Kein Ding. Aber ich benutze Linux und Windows zusammen.
Ich habe zwei Browser aus beiden Welten und mich nicht rum ärgern muss, dass ich das eine oder das andere nicht gescheit machen kann und das andere oder das andere nicht gescheit machen kann.
Einfach virtualisieren Linux unter Windows oder, wenn es einem reicht, WSL verwenden.
Das darfst du dem Hardcore-Linux-Fan aber nicht sagen. Dann wird er dir erst mal sagen, ja doch, mit Wine kannst du und du kannst hier und du kannst da und sonst was. Und es laufen ja sogar Steam und Steam-Spiele laufen zum größten Teil.
Aber da muss ich dir Recht geben für Noobs oder Leute, die einfach sagen, hey, ich habe mir was gelesen, ich möchte Spiele X und Y spielen, weil ich gerade einen Test drüber gelesen habe.
Vergiss es, das kannst du keinem zumuten, unter Linux zu spielen. Deswegen ist die beste Variante einfach ein Linux haben auf dem zweiten Desktop, so wie hier, und auf dem ersten Windows. Fertig.
Und das verwenden, wo das jeweilige System seine Stärken hat.
Das stimmt wohl, das stimmt wohl, aber ganz im Ernst, die meisten Probleme, die man heutzutage hat, wenn Windows crasht, sind irgendwelche Hardware-Dinger.
Und da hätte Linux auch seine Probleme mit. Du hast einfach vor allem eine Workstation auf Fullscreen, ja.
Naja, außer man hängt die falschen Parameter an Sudo dran. Wobei, nee, dann schützt es nicht ab, dann hat man Rutrechte, aber gut.
Aber das ist ja schon gefixt mittlerweile.
Das sagen immer alle, das ist aber nicht so. Ich quote das nochmal kurz.
Nein. Es stimmt, dass wohl jeder sich den Code angucken kann. Aber mal ganz im Ernst, niemand, außer vielleicht eine Handvoll Leute, blicken in den jeweiligen Kernel-Bereichen genug durch, um daran was zu ändern.
Nein, das kann nicht jeder. Es kann jeder an den Code gucken, aber es kann definitiv nicht jeder Bugs erkennen, geschweige denn fixen.
Garantiert nicht.
Und es könnte auch nicht jeder. Es ist unmöglich. Du hast vielleicht eine Handvoll Leute auf der Welt, die in manchen Bereichen im Lidungskernel durchblicken.
Das stimmt. Das ist wohl wahr.
Also generell hast du bei Open Source den Vorteil, du hast mehr Potenzial Sicherheitslücken zu finden, bevor sie relevant werden oder vielleicht auch schneller zu beheben.
Es kann sich jeder angucken, aber überlegt euch mal, wie viele Bugs auftauchen von Shellshock bis Hard Pleat bis irgendwelche Debian Geschichten, Random Return 5 und solche Sachen. Die waren teilweise ewig.
Die waren, wie will er sich sagen, Jahrzehnte, aber 5-6 Jahre oder so war es teilweise drin und unentdeckt. Also da blickt nicht viele Leute durch, geschweige denn gucken überhaupt rein.
Das stimmt wohl. Das stimmt.
Nix. Nix. Dem halben User geht das am Arsch vorbei.
Der 0815 User kauft sich das Ding, haut sich die Smartphone App drauf und macht sich doch keine Gedanken, ob da Linux drunter ist oder nicht.
Persönlich finde ich es natürlich geil, dass so viele Geräte auf Linux laufen und man dementsprechend auch an so vielen Geräten dann rumbasteln kann.
Ich bin ja auch Fan von wir flashen China-Chinesen-Geräte mit Tasmota, dass die China-Firmware runter ist.
Windows CE ist mal komplett für den Arsch. Aber ansonsten ist das für den normalen 0815 User, dem ist das doch egal.
Ja, Linux Mint würde ich auch empfehlen. Tja, Watch Videos, da haben wir es schon mal.
Du kannst unter Linux nicht einfach mal einen Browser öffnen und dann entspannt Videos gucken und dann auch hoffen, dass dein Rechner nicht am Anschlag ist, was die CPU-Leistung angeht bei 4K-Videos. Das funktioniert nicht.
Weil GPU-Decoding nur wenn die Planeten in der richtigen Konstellation stehen zur richtigen Uhrzeit und wenn ich vorher meinen Monitor dreimal links herum gedreht habe, dann GPU-Decoding funktioniert.
Du empfiehlst Arch, ich auch. Ich benutze auch Arch übrigens.
Du virtualisierst du Linux-Unterwindos oder umgehend? Ich virtualisiere Linux-Unterwindos.
Weil es einfacher ist, Linux-Unterwindos zu virtualisieren als Windows-Unterwindos.
Ich verwende Arch-Linux. Wobei ich verwende Manjaro. Das geht gar nicht als Arch-Linux durch, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Das ist eine Sache, da würde ich sofort zustimmen. Ja, du hast auch unter Linux öfters in letzter Zeit irgendwelche horrenden, bescheuerten Bugs gehabt.
Wie gesagt, hängst du an Sudo und Parameter hinten dran oder? Nein, Moment, das war nicht so. Du hängst Parameter an Sudo ran, du machst ein Symmling auf Sudo. So war das doch. Was da vor zwei Jahren so war, da kriegst du Hutrechte.
Ja, aber unterm Strich insgesamt, würde ich sagen, hast du unter Linux deutlich, deutlich weniger solcher Probleme. So Geschichten wie ein JavaScript-Interpreter im Windows-Defender mit Hutrechten, sowas hast halt unter Linux nicht.
Wann macht es denn Sinn, eher Windows zu verwenden, außer Gaming? Gaming? Oder aber du möchtest Software verwenden, die halt unter Linux nicht funktioniert.
Ja, sei es jetzt beispielsweise. Bei mir ist zum Beispiel Sony Vegas tut nicht unter Linux gescheit. Die Sachen, die ich für Thumbnails zum Erstellen benutze, funktionieren unter Linux nicht gescheit.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch ein bisschen nachdenken würde, bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen, dann kannst du vergessen oder auch wenn du zum Beispiel spezielle Hardware hast.
Ja, sagen wir jetzt mal, du hast irgendeinen Etikettendrucker oder so, wo ist da nur Windows-Software, wobei da mittlerweile auch einiges, also vieles zumindest unter Linux funktioniert, kannst du vergessen.
Oder du brauchst irgendwelche Hardware-Dongle, dass deine Software startet oder du hast irgendwelches olle Business-Zeug, was du brauchst, dass deine Firma läuft.
Also es gibt halt genug Sachen, die funktionieren nicht richtig unter Linux und die werden es wahrscheinlich auch nicht gescheit.
Wolltest du aber auf der Arbeit Outlook im Browser? Ja, mach ich. Echt? 2%? So viel haben wir mittlerweile? Na dann wird es ja mal Zeit, dann ist doch 2022 das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, oder? Was meint ihr?
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Gibt es eigentlich nicht. Ja, das stimmt.
Soho. Hört sich irgendwie unanständig an, oder? Soho.
Gibt es irgendeinen Nachteil bei Chromium? Je nachdem, welche Edition du verwendest, hast du halt manche Sachen nicht drinne. Du hast zum Beispiel bei manchen kein Chromecast drinne oder keine gescheite Hardware-Beschleunigung bei WebGL und solche Geschichten.
Musst genau gucken, welches Chromium-Bild du verwendest. Aber ansonsten hast du keine wirklichen Nachteile.
Angriff für den Zap. Ja. Das ist tatsächlich eines der riesen Dinger und was ich auch immer noch toll finde an Linux. Du musst dir keine Gedanken machen. Du brauchst keine Account. Du hast keinen Account-Zwang. Ja, lege jetzt einen Microsoft-Account an. Lege jetzt hier, lege jenes an. Hinterlege das hier und sonst was. Du hast keine Werbung. Du hast keine Ads. Du hast keine Ads. Du hast keinen Account-Zwang.
Du hast nichts, was dich nervt. Du kannst dir sicher sein, es schickt standardmäßig zumindest nichts, keine Software was heim. Wenn, dann hast du dich selbst installiert. Das ist tatsächlich eines der großen Vorteile auch für mich.
Also, man kann sicherlich deutlich beruhigter Linux verwenden als Windows. Und wenn ich mal auf irgendwelche Webseiten muss, die so ein bisschen shady sind, obwohl ich nicht genau weiß, ob sie nicht versuchen irgendwelche Viren unterzuschieben.
Vm an, Linux, Browser auf, drauf gehen, kann dir eigentlich nichts passieren. Ubuntu funkt mein, das willst du sagen. Ja, Ubuntu, das habe ich eh schon abgeschrieben. Ubuntu hatte doch auch mal diese Amazon-Werbung im Startmenü.
Ubuntu kann sich alles abschalten. Ja. Ja.
Ubuntu, wir wissen doch alle, dass das heißt, wenn man das richtig ausspricht.
Manjaro wird eigentlich auch von einem Unternehmen maintained. Nee, das ist von irgendeinem, ich glaube das sogar von irgendeinem Deutschen ist der Ober-Manjaro-Entwickler, irgendein Deutscher. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der gesponsert wird Fulltime für die Arbeit. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist richtig. Das ist schon richtig, aber man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Qualität vieler Open-Source-Alternativen, es ist auch egal, ob man die unter Windows oder Linux verwendet, nicht an bezahlte
Anwendungen rankommt. Es gibt genug Software, die ist frei und kostenlos und die ist besser als irgendwelchen Krempel, den du kaufst. Aber es gibt genauso gute Sachen, da findest du einfach nichts Gescheites.
Ich glaube Video Editor ist, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da was Gescheites gibt, was an sowas wie Vegas oder Premiere rankommt. Aber spätestens, wenn man anfängt mit Gimp versus, es muss ja nicht mal Photoshop sein, es reicht ja schon, wenn man hier mal die Billig-Dinger, die ich verwende, nimmt. Das kannst du knicken.
Blender ist Poggers. Ja, ich sag ja, es gibt genug Open-Source-Teils, was wirklich geil und wirklich nice ist. Aber es gibt halt auch umgedreht Dinger. Das ist halt, da merkst du schon, dass es halt ein Projekt ist, wo ein Typ am Wochenende ab und zu mal ein bisschen was dran bastelt.
Bei Blender ist das was anderes. Bei Blender stehen ja auch hunderte Leute und Contributors und alles mögliche dahinter.
Jetzt wollen sie ein bisschen Comments baiten, dass das für den Algorithmus besser ist.
Ja, sowas. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding. Wenn du zum Beispiel was suchst. Ja. Genau, sowas zum Beispiel. Oder auch wenn du was suchst, wo du gescheit für eine 3D-Drucker-Modelle machen kannst.
Sowas wie Fusion 360 und sowas. Das gibt es auch zum größten Teil nur Paid. In manchen Bereichen ist es super und lässt nichts zu wünschen übrig. In anderen Bereichen gibt es halt nicht viel.
Ich sag, da hab ich noch nichts mit gemacht. Ich kann mir bloß nicht vorstellen, dass das, da glaub ich dir das einfach mal.
Also gerade bei denen hier im Leben nicht. Im Leben nicht als Alternative zu Vegas oder Premiere.
Und ist das nicht irgendwo so eine Effektgeschichte? Das weiß ich nicht, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ja gut, das heißt ja nichts. Dann ist anscheinend wirklich der Alternative. Nur weil im professionellen Umfeld irgendwo was verwendet wird, ist es immer noch kein Ersatz für einen Nord-15-Typ, der daheim ein Thumbnail oder ein Video für YouTube machen will.
Es ist gut, dass es was gibt, aber im Bildbearbeitungsbereich ist es immer noch mau. Und ich denke auch gerade was Audiobearbeitung angeht, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie es da aussieht.
Wenn es nicht free ist, dann sind wir ja beim Thema, dass man eben manche Software einfach nichts Gutes bekommt, was aus Open Source Ecke.
Ja Audacity kannst du ja nicht wirklich als Audiobearbeitung durchgehen lassen. Audacity verwende ich auch, um auf Aufnahme zu drücken, mein Kram einzusprechen und fertig.
Aber das kannst du ja nicht mit irgendeiner Audio Workstation vergleichen.
Ja das kann, möglich, möglich, aber das kannst du trotzdem nicht mit irgendwelchen, wie gesagt ich bin im Audiobereich nicht so an. Das kenne ich mir nicht so aus. Aber wenn ich mir angucke, was ich da beispielsweise schon in Videos gesehen habe von Leuten, die auf ihrem, in dem Fall war es eine Mac, ihre Digital Audio Workstation aufhaben, da kannst du nicht mit Audacity dagegen anscheißen.
Kennst du den Metalab aus? Nö.
Es ist gut, dass es immer mehr gibt, aber in manchen Bereichen kommst du nicht drum herum. Warum löscht du eigentlich immer die 1 aus dem Blick? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1, da habe ich das versucht zu erklären.
Genau.
Das ist kein Gescheite, was heißt kein Gescheite, das ist diesen ganzen Office-Krempel unter Linux, ich weiß, dass es LibreOffice gibt. Unter Linux nicht gibt, juckt mich persönlich gar nicht, weil ich verwende keine Office-Programme für nichts.
Ja, das ist warum ich die 1 kopiere.
Stimmt, ja tatsächlich Office 365 kannst du verwenden. Wusst du, dass Office 365 React basiert ist?
JavaScript, Stells, Kram. Ja, das stimmt, Office 365 kannst du verwenden. PowerPoint im Browser ist kuselig, du wirst lachen, meine letzten Präsentationen der letzten Jahre habe ich alle über PowerPoint im Browser gemacht.
Das hat nämlich einen großen Vorteil, man kann mit Leuten zusammen editieren und man sieht dann was der andere editiert. Wenn es nach mir geht, würde ich dafür auch keinen PowerPoint verwenden, aber bei mir in der Firma ist das so, die stehen da unglaublich drauf, wenn man diese Corporate Vorlage verwendet.
Und wenn man nicht die Corporate Vorlage verwendet, wirst du gleich Shep angeguckt. Normalerweise, wisst ihr was ich normalerweise machen würde? Ich würde 5 Markdown Seiten machen, einen PDF draus exportieren und fertig.
Ja gut, bringt ja nichts, PowerPoint selbst läuft ja unter Linux nicht, bleibt dir nur Office 365 dran.
Präsentations-Livestream, ne das ist ein bisschen zu viel firmeninternes Zeug, oder?
Ja genug Unverwundbarkeits-Sound. Braucht darüber meine Katze, da muss ich aber keine Präsentation zumachen.
Ok Leute, schon spät, was ist jetzt? Richtig, Bedgetime, 22 Uhr gleich.
So sieht es aus.
Muss ich mir mal überlegen, die Katze rennt hier im Flur rum.
Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns, bis zum nächsten Stream.